Now we're getting, uh,   a
slightly higher rated opponent. And again we
have white.    Okay,
so we're going to start with E four.
And we're rated
1333. Good rating. And we're facing the
Scandinavian. Great. The first time, I
think, in the speed run that we have faced a
scandal. Correct me if I'm wrong. Of course,
the move move is he takes D five and night F
six. This is like the poor man Scandy.
I think it might be called the Portuguese.
Well, there is a line here that's called the
Portuguese gambit. This is not it.
This is again but technically,
yes, but White is not supposed to
keep the extra pawn. So, first of all,
you might ask, well, why not? Why not simply
C two? C four. So the
reason is that black responds
with C six. And it's important to
have command of basic positional
principles to even understand how this
sacrifice works. After C
six, white can transpose to the pan off car
O'Connell show you after the game. Or
white can play D, take Csync, which is the
greedy approach, but in the resulting
position, again, I'll show you the position
after the game. Black's got
massive control over the center, in
particular, a stronghold on D four. And
White's got a terrible lightscored bishop
that's just biting on the C four
pawn. So there's a variety of
factors that give Black tremendous
compensation for the pawn. And so
the line that you might have seen me
play in blitz, actually, my coach taught me
this line years and years ago. It served me
very well. It's easy to learn
and it's cool. It demonstrates some
positional principles. We start
by checking on B five, which is
kind of weird. It's weird that the first
move we make is with the Bishop.
But, uh, the check itself should make sense
to you. It's the developing move with
tempo. And obviously, if Black plays
C six now, then of course, we play
DC. And we haven't pushed the seep on
up to C Four. So that makes no sense for
Black. Black can cover the check in one
of two ways. There is night B to D seven
here, which is a viable
move, but most people go Bishop D
seven. And then the idea is, hey,
that Bishop on D seven. Is it well
placed? Well, absolutely
not. It's depriving the B eight knight of a
square. It's cutting the contact
between Black's queen and the center.
It's just standing in the middle of
absolutely everything. And that
Bishop absolutely sucks. We should leave it
there. Right. And this is kind of the
idea of provoking a particular
move that ends up being counterproductive to
the opponent. Now, you might logically
then, reason that we should play
Bishop back to C Four if we're already
moving the Bishop. Well, perhaps we should
defend the pawn while we're at it. And
I'll show you some theory after the game.
But Bishop C four is not the move I was
taught. It is a reasonable move. But
after bishop c four, it allows Bishop
to g four. That's the
problem. And bishop to g
four. Well, what does it do? It attacks the
Queen. It puts the Bishop on a better
square. And while we can play, uh, F
three there, that's not a move you want to
be making in the opening. And we
might also not be able to keep our
extra pawn on D five. So
how do we circumvent that? Well, a lot of
you guys are not fully understanding
the point of what I just said. You're
proposing, queen e two or a four? And these
are moves which give Black a way
out, right? They allow the Bishop
trade. They allow Black to eradicate
this awkward piece on D seven. So we
actually physically need to move the Bishop
away, and we move it to E
two in order to stop Bishop G
four. And that was a very kind of
verbose explanation of this
line. But I'm trying to lay the
groundwork so that you don't forget  why
this move is played, because this is an easy
move to to butcher.   Okay, so the
idea is to stop Bishop G four. And the idea
of moving the Bishop at all
is so that after a move like a
four, black doesn't rid
himself of this awkward piece
by agreeing to the Bishop trade and
then taking on D five, let's say, with the
Queen. Now, Queen E Two does prevent the
immediate Bishop takes B five, because this
is a fork. But after Queen E
two, white would play or,
uh, Black would play just Knight takes D
five, right? And ask you what you're doing
on B Five.   So
we continue by
occupying the center with our pawn. We play
d four.   And it's important
to start with D four, because if you
play the slightly sloppy Knight
F three, you allow the extra option of the
Night jumping into F four, and
suddenly, like, the Bishop is under fire
and G two is under fire. So we
should prevent that and grab
the center at the same time. Now, you would
be correct if you're kind of assuming that
we're going to place C four. We're going to
do that. We don't have to do that
immediately. That move is not going to be
taken away from us. But C Four is going to
come, and it's going to push the Night away
from D five, and we're going to have nice
development and better central control and
why it's going to have a small but stable
advantage that's going to be the roadmap in
this position. Now, we should start
here with a simple developing
move. Let's get the Night out to F
three and then actually let's
castle. And only then I think
we should play C four. Although, uh,
conversely, you could say here
we're giving Black actually an extra option.
It's not like, scary, but Black can play
bishop F Eight to D six,
intending to meet C Four with
knight to F uh, four. So that
is an option that we've provided to Black.
But it's we'll find a way around it. We
don't have to play. C four against Bishop. D
six.     So
our next move likely to be castles and then
C Four and knight C three. And the
development in this line is very simple, but
I like the way our opponent is handling
this. C Five is a good move. Black
contests the center,
and Black basically forces
our hand. Right.    I
just said that our next move is going to be
to Castle. And castling here is
fine, but I think
the opportune moment has
come to play. What move?
We should try to meet Black in the center.
We shouldn't just give Black free reign in
the center. We should try to fight for the
center. And we should do it by playing C
Four. Let's knock the night out immediately.
If we castle instead, Black will take
on C Four and then simply
go night C six. And by the time we
go C Four, black might
have some weird tactics going
on that might make C Four less
effective. So let's do it now
while Black still hasn't completed their
development,    and
then, uh, we'll castle and proceed with our
development ourselves.     Okay,
so if night before, then we can
just play A three, that's not
dangerous. There are some lines in, like,
the Alokine and Scandi where
if the, uh, lights go Bishop is on F
five, then night B Four is
actually a very unpleasant move to face
because it threatens to fork Blackbase night
F six. Okay, well, again, we have
alternatives here. We can play night night
to C Three, which we're going to play. We
can castle. That's also possible.
Now, the move D Five might look very
appealing. Oh, let's push the pawn down,
create a passer. But D Five is
actually totally innocuous because Black
and Trade. And if you have
a pass pawn that's isolated this
early in the game, it's likely to
be a liability. It's not actually going
anywhere because Black can
blockade it by putting the dark squid Bishop
on D six. So instead of
hastily rushing forward, let's keep the
tension by developing our pieces and
play Nt three. And obviously, CD we
recapture with the knight. Right.
Recapturing with the Queen just doesn't make
much sense,    uh, because it
walks right into night C six. What are we,
scandy players?
John Bretha would recommend Queen 64 and
then Queen H Four, but we're keeping
things principled, and
we're playing by the book.
Okay.
Night. C
six. Now, an important
rule that I have
echoed, uh, already many times in the
speedrun is just because
throughout all of the speedruns is just
because an idea doesn't work in one position
doesn't mean you should rule it out in
another. Right.   Circumstances and
chess change very quickly. Like a
single move can make an idea
suddenly work. It can
bring an idea up from the dead. And this is
a great example of that right now. D
Five, it makes perfect sense to play this
move because this is the way that we keep
the initiative going. It's a tempo move. It
attacks the night. But most importantly, it
doesn't give Black the time that he needs to
put his pants on with Bishop D Six. Right?
Because by the time Black plays that move
well, first of all, we can prevent Black
from playing that move by doing what what
development move is going to prevent bishop
D Six? Well, it's obviously the move Bishop
F Four, which we could throw in, and that's
the move we want to play anyway. And you
might say, well, why is it important that
we're preventing Bishop D Six? Well, that's
because Bishop D Six is the only way to
blockade this past pawn. So, if you can
imagine, after Bishop F Four, bishop E
Bishop is literally almost trapped.
So at this point, the past pawn has suddenly
become a great asset. 94 makes no
sense. That just blunders upon. We
have two attackers on the D Four
square. So immediately our
opponent reacts   in
a panicked way to the pressure and blunders
upon. Right? This is how quickly you can get
players to crumble if you
play principled openings and
you just follow the freaking rules, you
know.    So Black now
has to tread very carefully
because, again, Bishop B Seven, we
drive the pond down to D six.
He goes. Bishop B four. That's a good
move.   Now, what should we
do here? Should we go? D six.
Well, we can play D Six,
but D Six seems a lot less
impressive when it doesn't gain a
tempo or drive the bishop back. I actually
don't like D Six because of this weird
move, queen B six.
And the idea should be clear. You're trying
to force a queen trade. And then the pawn is
without a guardian and Black is coming in
with 94.   That seems
too concrete. We should just castle and we
shouldn't play A three, right? I would draw
a parallel with the E four B
six game. It's in the previous speedrun
video or two videos ago, I guess,
where we don't
need to deal with the pin. By
forcibly chasing the bishop away. We can
just take the sting out of it by
castling. Right now, the knight can move.
And what we ultimately want is for Black to
take on C Three himself,
uh, because that loses a
tempo in comparison with a three. Another
very interesting, subtle point I think you
guys will enjoy. If we play A
three here, we take away the A
three square from our bishop, and you might
say, well, how is the bishop ever going to
get that square? Well, guess what? If Black
takes on c three himself. Then after
BC, our dark squared, bishop actually has a
very nice developing post on a three,
which we don't really want to take away
with the pawn. And that's an example of a
super minor positional point
that I would incorporate into my thinking
if I'm, let's say, a GM,
right? You'd make these small observations
like, oh, I don't want to play a three
because maybe I'll need that square for one
of my minor pieces five moves later. I don't
know. But you try to play with
maximum flexibility  and
make the least amount of commitments
possible, and you continue doing that in
this position by developing your pieces.
Right. The best way to
make good moves without committing is just
to develop. So what developing move M
remains? Well, it's to develop the
dark squid. Bishop, where should we put it?
Well, that's pretty obvious from this
position, bishop G Five, as it did
in the previous million games.
Uh, and we seem to be doing this,
like, with both colors every game, right?
This pin is super
underrated. It's actually an incredibly
dangerous pin in most
situations where Black is Castle of
Kingside, and it's even more dangerous
here because the queen is pressuring the
knight, and the 94 is a
huge threat as well. And let's
not forget that Bishop E Seven, which
I've previously pointed out is a way to take
the sting out of the pin, fails in this
position to
D.   Okay? H Six.
Well, again,   we can trade. We can play
bishop takes F six. But it's a little bit
early to trade queens here, because trading
queens really relieves the pressure on
Black's position. If we were a piece
up, if the bishop wasn't on before,
I would advocate an approach of
simplification. But when you're a pawn up,
uh,    that rule kind
of goes out the window. In many
cases, when you're a pawn up, you actually
don't want to trade queens when you're a
piece up, in most cases, a queen trade
does help you simplify the position.
So we just keep the tension with Bishop
H four.
And if Black plays G five, well,
that is an amazing thing to
provoke in this position, which already
sucks for Black. Imagine if Black also
weakens the knight and weakens the king
permanently. That's just going to be too
much to handle.
And, of course, Bishop B seven is
played nicely.
Walking into our idea,
and what I love is that the
past pawn ends up deciding the game.
The game is not decided if Black
finds a small, tricky move, but then we
can respond with an accurate move of
our own and end the game. So what
tricky idea does Black have
here? And I think our opponent is likely to
play this move.
So notice that the queens
are in an X ray. Well, queen B
Six, a mirror white can just take
the queen and take the bishop, right? That's
not very tricky. I'm talking about bishop
c six.
Anytime the queens are in a file,
you're always looking for tactics that try
to exploit the undefended
nature of one of the queens. So
bishop c six precludes c takes
c seven. That gives up the queen on d four
for insufficient material. What should
we do against bishop c six? And there is
a mopois here, as my 6th grade math teacher
would say, most popular wrong answer.
There's a move which looks surface level
tempting, but then there is a move which
actually wins the game. And let's see if
anybody falls for the tempting move.
Nobody's falling for the
tempting move. I love seeing this. To me,
c five might be a temptation,
right? Oh, let's connect the pawns, because
I remember from the speedrun that the best
way to defend a pawn is with another pawn.
But concrete
considerations always take precedent
over these general rules.  You're trying
to make a move that protects the
Queen and protects the pawn at the same
time. And the move that satisfies those
constraints is rook eight to d one,
and that ends the game immediately.
We won't need to play it because it
renews the threat of de, and
it keeps the bishop trapped.
Queen takes d six, the most popular
on answer to be avoided at all times. And
the game is essentially over. We've won a
minor piece, and we also
stand to trade queens very shortly because
black essentially has no way of avoiding
the Queen trade. And the Queen trade
is going to really simplify things and help
us win fast and
easily.
Black has a couple of other moves. I
guess queen e eight would be a way to avoid
the Queen trade, but that's not
serious. Okay, so we can do a
million different things here to win. I
won't belabor the point. We have
a, uh, really pretty and very
elegant tactical idea, though, if we want to
win a second piece. I just saw this.
So it starts with a move that you should
want to play anyway. There is a move that
you should want to play, and you should want
to play it because it
clearly induces weaknesses in black's
position, and it simplifies the
position, so it checks off more than one
box. What am I talking about? Well,
it's the move bishop takes f six, noticing,
of course, that the queen cannot
recapture because the queen takes d seven.
So bishop f six, black, has to play GF,
and that creates massive weaknesses
on black's kingside. But let's be more
specific.
How does it change the
kingside pawn structure? Well, you might
think and say the g seven pawn moves to f
six. That's all that's happened. What
is the consequence of that? What is the
result of that? Well, the result of that is
that the g file has opened up. So there has
appeared a new possibility.
Queen d six to g three. Check. But playing
that move immediately would be kind of lame,
right? Because then the king would just move
over to H eight. But we should keep that in
our pocket, and we should make what move?
Before playing Queen G. Three. We combine
again,   several different
factors in the position. You also know that
the D file shit stuff
is going down down the D file. You play rook
eight at e one, and if the bishop
moves, then the rook is x raying
the queen, and the queen drops back to
G three with check, and we win the queen
on D eight. If black doesn't move the
bishop, then we simply win the bishop.
So that's how you construct a combination.
And this is a combination. It doesn't
involve any sacrifices, but it's a sequence
of moves that, uh, has the aim
of delivering checkmate or winning material,
which is what, uh, I define
personally as a combination.
So, rook 80, D one hits the
bishop seems to have nothing to do
with the king, and yet it does. If the
bishop moves, queen G three is a backward
retreating discovered check against
black's king.
Little combination here, Pete.
Combination,     as
they say in French.
Does it matter which rook you move?
Not here. No. Here you can move either. But
rook 81 is more open. Now, rookie seven is a
move you had to foresee.
But, uh, the reason
heavy pieces are bad defenders is because
they're easy to attack. So, at this point,
the move should just come naturally to you
should notice that the bishop on D seven
is hanging by a thread,
right? It's on life support. So all
you need to do is play knight to B
five. This move really
does play itself. If black takes the
knight, you're spoiled for choice, but you
can still play queen G three, check, winning
the queen and then winning the rook on C
seven. Of course, the simpler move is just
to take the queen straight away. Also
possible   if black doesn't
react within the rook. And if black moves
the rook, we take the bishop, and we're up
two minor pieces.
So
I will say that, of course, you could
start with rook 81, and you would still
be winning. But it's less precise
after rook 81, bishop C
six, right? You can't then say, oh, now
let's take on F six, because then the queen
can already capture because the bishop has
moved away from the undefended square.
So, order of operations here is very
important. Another move that some people
suggest here is knight to e four.
Terrible move because black can actually
take the night simultaneously hitting
white's queen   white is still
winning after that by miracle.
But it's not to be advised.
Okay,
nehel says, I didn't see how we
were winning the bishop. Well,
if the bishop doesn't move, then we just
take it with our queen, right? Because we've
got two attackers on the bishop. So
either the bishop moves and we win the black
queen. Or the bishop doesn't
move and we win the bishop.
Black
reporting me as we speak. Well, this was a
nice game. Yeah, this
was a pretty,  uh, lethal sequence of
moves.   And the decisive
mistake, if we're speaking at a
very high level now, of course, the decisive
mistake was 94. And I'll talk more about
this after the game. Let's actually finish
the game in style. Let's make sure we're
not, uh,  jumping the gun here.
And queen g three chuck is
the most accurate move,
opening up a discovery
against the queen, which we take.   Do we
take the bishop? No, we take the rook on the
next move, which is now hanging,  it
has lost the support of the
queen, which we've captured. So
everything falls here, and
now we're actually winning the bishop. It's
hilarious. We won the queen, then we won the
rook, and then we're winning the bishop all
in a row.    Just
decisive lethal
crushing.  All right, quick
look over. Even though this was a pretty
straightforward game,   so we will
separate queen takes d five. We won't talk
about this right now. We'll face it again.
Uh, I'm positive we'll face it
again.    Uh, and we'll be able to
spend dedicated time on it. Night f six is
a fundamentally different line. It's really
not popular anymore. It's been
played a lot by GMs, but
black knows that he's worse, right?
And white is a million ways here to cement
the advantage. So you might analyze with
stockbridge 15 and find that mission b five
trick is not really the best move. I need to
update my analysis of this line.
I'm    sharing
thoughts from, like, 2011 or 2012, which is
when I remember this from. But still, it's
not going to ruin the advantage. So I will
mention that if if black plays knight beat a
d seven, the simplest
the simplest sequence here is just to play d
four. Knight takes d five, and knight f
three. Just develop your frickin
pieces, and if black plays a
six, then you can drop the bishop back to
this nice active square on d
three. Okay? So this is, uh, a
straightforward advantage, and after bishop
d seven, we play bishop e two.    Okay?
So,    of course,
black should take the pawn on d five.
And the next couple of moves
were totally,  uh,
understandable, and they were valid by
black. So c five, I actually
like, knight f six is
fine. And here things
go completely haywire for
black. Obviously, knight c six is
just an incredibly careless move that walks
into d five. Our opponent just
forgets about this move
correct. Would have been to take on d
four to finally eliminate the tension.
And only after knight takes d four is it
time to develop the knight. And
I think white is
slightly better after he castles, but
not that much. I mean, black intake and
start simplifying, and
white is a more pleasant position,
a, uh, space advantage on the queen side.
It's nice, but it really might not
be the best way to punish the NITF six line.
So another thing I forgot to
point out is just to show you on the
board why C four, C
six, and DC is not the
way to go.   So white
might be not worse here, but I actually
think white is worse after knight takes C
six.    By the way, the best move
here for white is to play D four and
knight C three. And this transposes
into the pawn of variation of the
Karo Khan. It's a famous
transposition pawn of variation happens
takes takes D four nine, F six, nine, C
three. The reason is because the same moves
are played. They're just played in a
different order, right? In one order, black
plays D five, C, uh, six, and then D five,
and the other black plays D five, and then C
six. So it's not mind
boggling that we get a
transposition. But in this position,
after knight F three, E five,
I've talked about this
type of position through the lens of a
different line, where in the Sicilian, white
plays F four.   Now,
does anybody remember
what black's move is in this position?
And speed Turkey?
It's an interesting question. Let me get to
it in a second. The move here is actually D
five immediately striking
ed five. We play Night, F
six, C four, we play E six, and
we get a very similar type of situation.
So you can find my speedrun game on this
line and listen to my
explanation because it's the same thing.
It's the same weakness of the square. It's
the same bad bishop. And here you also have,
uh, the really bad move, F four. So this is
even worse for white. But
comparatively, it's pretty simple. Blacks
got D Four, blacks got Bishop coming out to
G four, the other bishop coming out to C
five. And after D three,
black can actually just immediately strike
with E four. Black can make this tactical
and trade queens. And black still
has a massive initiative in the end game. I
mean, just look at this. Bishop E three,
bishop F five, castles, queen side.
Everything is coming out with
tempo. And this is just
nasty, nasty stuff, right? So don't do
that.   Now, Speed Turkey is
asking    how is it that
bishop B five check gains a tempo,
right, as compared to
the immediate bishop B two?
Well, the answer is
basically, first of all, that here black
S queen takes D five, which is an entire
additional option.
Second of all, black can make the clever
move C six here, which is kind of
annoying,   right? Which
which isn't as effective
here. Here, if black plays C six, we take
it. And after knight C six, the
concrete difference is that
we can actually play D four,
right? And this move is a
game changer because it occupies the
center. If the Bishop is still on C
A,   then in this line, we
can't go D Four because of knight takes D
Four. So that's a very subtle reason. The
Bishop D Seven is a positive provocation,
but also and the main reason is
that it precludes. It precludes
the tempo move. Queen Takes D. Five. And as
far as I know, White is still better here.
So the answer is yes. You could play Bishop
B Two first. But Bishop B five is slightly
more accurate. It gives life more rope to
hang himself. So it's concrete. It's
concrete. In any case,
after D Five, the game is very close to
being over. That's how powerful this
pawn is. Now, what should Black have done
in this position? I actually
think, amazingly enough, that
94 is the right
idea. I think it's basically the right
move. If Black tries to conserve material
and play 97
okay, this just looks horrible.
D Six has come in and Night B Five, and
I feel like this is already winning for
White. So that's kind of out of the
question. Night B Four is another move, but
here we can chase the night further and
then still play D Six. And this pawn just
looks like a beast. We can
always support it with the Bishop.
And in a line like this, I mean,
come on. Night A Four actually traps the
queen, which is totally
vicious. Like, look at that.
And bishop a four. Queen A Four is just a
total destruction. And devastation cuts
us off. Black, uh, is
collapsing.     Oh,
Lord. So anytime White plays D
Six,    it just hails
destruction in its wake. It wreaks havoc.
So the idea to sack
upon and develop is a good one
and just file this away in your sort of
mental cabinet. This is a common idea
you sacrifice upon. What do you
sacrifice? Sacrifice it for for the
right to develop a piece to gain a
tempo, like you're sacking for a
tempo. And the tempo is used
to get the Dark Squad Bishop out. So 94
is the top engine move,     and
as a result of the trade, it's Black to
play, and Black gets the Bishop just in time
to D Six. Now, obviously, White can trade it
off with Bishop F four. It's plus
minus. White is a pawn up. There's no
compensation. Nobody's disputing that.
But after the trade and the
castle, Black can still defend. At least
Black is castled, at least Black isn't.
Checkmated.   It's interesting,
says Tube Disaster, that a lot of chess
moves are to provoke bad moves by the
opponent. Absolutely.
That's a fascinating property of chess,
how, as my friend used to call it, you're
moving your opponent's pieces as well as
yours, and that's an art to
move your opponent's pieces onto
the worst possible squares for them.
So, anyways, this might have been the final
chance.   As it stood,
Black inverted. The move order. And
now if Black plays Ed,
we actually might have
ignored the pawn entirely and
gone something like bishop G five
just     quickly
completing the development. This looks like
a terrifying position for Black. Just look
at the pressure on all of the
diagonals. Maybe the engine can hold this
together, but
in human games you often get something like
this and White just wins a piece.
So there were some move order issues, but I
still think Ed was the best move.
Once our opponent
doesn't display a sense of urgency and we
get our pieces out. Okay, the situation
now is absolutely dire.
The engine suggests to take on C
three   and to play some
abstract move like rookie A. Just sit tight,
try to go E Five.
Black's position is crap. I mean, we can go
rook A B one and we can go rook Fe one
and we can bring the bishop to F three. I
mean, white is just technically winning, no
question about it.   Okay? This
was technically the way to survive
after    still rookie eight here
is a move or bishop takes C three, but
Bishop E 76 just loses the
game. Again, we put so much pressure,
our opponent collapses,
and   most uh,   importantly,
bishop C six. Rook A to D one is the
crushing move because it renews the
threat of bishop of D seven.
And at the end of the day, we're just up a
full piece. And I won't elaborate at length
about how to win that endgame  in the game.
We didn't need to win an endgame because we
spotted it the combination. We start by
taking the night off the board, opening up
the G file. We conclude by attacking
the bishop, getting it to move, and
discovering the check against Black's queen
Brook C 795. And this
speaks for itself. We take the queen,
we take the rook, and we win the game. So
a 22 move game, but a lot
happens. We had an interesting opening
discussion. I didn't delve too deeply into
the theory of this line because it's so rare
and because   I, uh,  might actually analyze
it and recommend something different. But
hopefully you got the point of this. Bishop
B five. Bishop B two. Line. You understood
the urgency of playing D four before
nightFREE. You kind of got a general sense
for this structure, which is always a
positive way to further your understanding,
right? Every structure, every
correlation of pawns can happen in one of
your games. And you're like, wait, hey, I
know what the ideas are here. I know what
I'm supposed to do. I'm going to go
D. That's how you learn, right? You
learn not just based on tactics, but you
learn structures. And structures
define plans, and plans can be
repeated.     Uh,
so you shouldn't just think of this as an
opening speeder, and you should think of
this as something that's giving you ideas
that you can use across many different types
of openings.
So last thing I'll say D
five here. I talked about this.
We don't want to go D Five before night C
Six    because it allows the
Bishop to blockade us. And we haven't even
won a pawn in contrast to that other line.
So here, Black is actually totally fine.
So it's very important to
wait for Black to go 96.
Okay, guys, I will conclude
here. Um, I'm exhausted, but
those were two awesome
speedrun games.   I hope
you guys enjoyed them. Once again,
thank you all, uh,
for supporting me. The subscriptions on
Twitch, YouTube, they help
tremendously.   This is my living.
So thank you, everybody, for supporting
hope you enjoyed hanging out,
and I will see you guys tomorrow. Thank
you, everybody, for watching. Have a good
one. See you tomorrow. Bye.